[Musique]
à l'occasion de cette journée mondiale
de l'aviation civile l'invité de 5 à 10
ce matin christian ducteil vous êtes
correspondant de presse pour plusieurs
journaux dont le quotidien france
antilles et à cosmos vous êtes également
un spécialiste de l'aérien et c'est pour
cela que vous êtes que vous êtes là pour
parler du ciel martiniquais qui est très
convoité par les compagnies aériennes
bonjour aux christian ducteil bonjour
alors dernier a company pour l'instant
arrivée en martinique et on dit bien
pour l'instant et on verra pourquoi par
la suite la compagnie level qui a
annoncé dix vols à partir de septembre
prochain à destination de la martinique
au départ d'orly les vols low cost à
partir de 99 euros qu'est ce qui fait
l'attrait des compagnies low cost pour
la martinique ben si une compagnie
celui-ci la venue sur la martinique
c'est parce que il y appellera en
retirer puisque bon il ya un flux
passagers quand même intéressant entre
les gentils et la france il ya un public
pour ce type d'offre oui je peux dire
qu'il ya un public pour ce type d'offres
parce qu'ils voulaient entre les
vacances qui serait pas basée en france
qu'ils soient plus poussés à ses études
en france doit bien venir faire son
carnaval où l'on retrouve sur la
martinique dont 90
euros s'est approprié d'accord 99 euros
qu'est ce qu'on a pour ça
le siège
pourtant utile de voir sous un siège
c'est intéressant quand même voilà et
oui mais on n'a pas donc 99 euros quand
on regarde l'offre de level on a
effectivement que le siège de bagages de
cabine et c'est tout pas de repas pas de
bagages en soute mais ça suffit
largement lorsque vous prenez un taxi
pour aller sur
fort-de-france - deux fois les chiffres
de cette année les chalets cette année
et fort de france je pense que chapeau à
chaque fois suffit largement est ce que
ce n'est pas une façon de relancer le
tourisme sac à dos
partant de paris pour arriver en
martinique touristes chaque année je
pense plus que la clientèle visée c'est
aussi la caserne martiniquaise parce que
bon comme j'ai dit tout à l'heure ça
pourrait impulser c'est quelqu'un qui
voit 90 fort-de-france
de transport mais un tout et sac à dos
aussi n'est pas très évident pour lui
aussi venu par lamartine pour peu à peu
de frais comment les compagnies
peuvent-elles proposer de tels tarifs
les plus importants s'il faut remarquer
que le vin est une compagnie basée hors
de france et la masse salariale joue un
rôle important dans
pour ce qui des étals des billets
s'étaient vu que ses compagnes l'as roma
ce roman sera basée au de france
sont moins importants dans d'autres pays
ça favorise d'avoir le talent est
intéressant je vais pas trop de détails
oui mais il ya pas une question de taxes
aussi non latrive on vous paie a même
pas ce que tu dis compagnies savent les
antilles
ce qui se passe yves surtout point de
vue des salaires des pilotes des
hôtesses de l'air d'accord de sécurité
ils ont les mêmes ils sont amis vous que
toute notre compagnie ce sont des
compagnies fiable de haut niveau de la
situation peut dire ça je crois qu'à
l'espèce un loto easyjet silence et la
frontière qu'elle avait par ailleurs
france et que son personnel est basé en
angleterre lol bénéficier des salaires
intéressants et ont manqué bien ça a été
ça fait un court exposé puisqu'il se
permet même de faire des vols à
l'intérieur de la france et d'ailleurs
paris nantes à tous à papa au fait
qu'ils bénéficient de salaires moindres
pas pareil en france
d'accord level et pour l'instant je le
disais tout à l'heure la tergnier a
company men norvégienne qui fait déjà
les états unis
prévoient de se mettre également sur le
transatlantique bas mais avant tout il
ya peine un an un an le qu'on en parle
et je trouve même qu'il prenne du temps
qu'ils prennent le temps voilà ce qui
signifie que hrw effectivement il ya ya
une clientèle pour ça il ya une
clientèle qui serait prête à payer peu
avant un service moindre
8 heures de vol ont eu tort le vol moi
j'estime que c'est abordable alors on
voit que la compétition fait rage quels
seront alors les conséquences d'accord
les prix à l'organisation n'aura que des
prix bas mais est ce que le risque se de
ne pas devoir ou compagnes ils restés
sur le carreau
on as échoué je ne pense pas je préfère
elle n'a pas par exemple des trois
compagnies traditionnelles je parle de
corsair et air caraïbes et air france
est ce que ça ne risque pas de les
pénaliser uyar d'alépé de la risée
peut-être mais c'est mieux que s atteler
à tous ces compagnies là ne sont pas
venus là comme ça je pense que s'attend
à un changement de situation et au fur
et à mesure fut des temps ils vont
on voit leur configuration mais je ne
pense pas que ça pourrait avoir une
incidence réelle sur ces compagnies vous
qui avez l'habitude d'analyser un peu le
ciel et les offres des compagnies
comment les compagnies traditionnelles
pourraient réagir face à face à cette
offensive leurs atouts c'est à dire je
prends le cas des caraïbes cas il faut
pas nous locale on a tous cru avril des
salariés locaux ça c'est un point et ça
en mettant en avant le client que tu
vois ça ouais un tel pilote de ligne
intel hôtesses de la saveur dossier
davantage il faut pour le cadet à france
l'atout des français c'est la
possibilité de dispatcher les passagers
en domestique sur la france c'est à dire
un client doit à paris et depuis paris
pour aller en province concède une
compagnie qui a
notoriété ne petite compagnie aérienne
dit de tous mais qu'il a depuis
longtemps et cette notoriété là aussi
vous pourrez donc copié compagnie l'a16
à tous les niveaux est bon pour le jeu
tandis qu'une compagnie qui débute comme
level aura à faire à faire ses preuves
voilà le message
avoir pléthore de compagnie est ce que
ça ne me risque pas de jouer aussi sur
l'emploi parce qu'on voudrait parler des
emplois locaux est-ce qu'on va pas
devoir moment parce qu'il faudra
peut-être s'aligner sur les prix est ce
que les compagnies traditionnelles ne
vont pas devant un moment dégraisser
localement on sent que c'est pas un
risque en valeur et du temps au temps
bon allez chez les compagnies
offert mes yeux du tango l'ouvrons
s'aménager et là on verra comment les
chaussures perchées
autre stat gym vous le disiez tout à
l'heure c'est l'offre d'arrivée pas que
paris c'est à dire que le transfert ne
se fera plus
pour les compagnies traditionnelles vers
orly par exemple ou bien voilà c'est
surtout orly mais verdes en direct vers
les provinces vers d'autres aéroports
oui mais la ccsa les atouts là tout
ça pour ça pour les différencier de
lever parce qu'ils veulent on arrive
simplement à paris
d'accord
combien de temps
peut durer encore l'offre level est ce
que ce n'est pas juste un coup ce qu'on
avait vu ça je sais plus où j'étais
c'était air liberté l'ancien nom d'air
lib donc est ce que c est ce que c'est
une offre qui va durer dans le temps
si les expéditions les proprios de level
c'est eux qui ont qui savent comment ils
vont gérer leurs affaires ici la
clientèle ce qui fera la différence qui
saura qui verra à quel moment que l'on a
pu les les tables que level propose pour
revenir à une autre question si si si le
dans ses offres là il faut j'ai regardé
les détails c'est ça exactement c'est à
dire garder les détails qu'est ce qu'il
faut qu'est ce qu'il faut regarder
qu'est-ce qu'il faut comparer belle la
qualité de l'offre
le bagage
hong kong rudy d'ailleurs la procédure
pour les films enfin les prestations que
nos propos c'est pour différentes
compagnies aériennes là d'accord
effectivement on oublie on n'y pense pas
toujours mais avoir la possibilité
d'avoir un écran individuel
ça fait partie maintenant des classiques
des trucs que je veux dire habituel et
que l'on n'a pas obligatoirement dans
les offres à 99 euros chercher une
différence quand on fait durer le vol
et c'est vrai que ça fait une différence
on peut se passer de repas il faut
pouvoir se distraire point là d'accord
face à sète parlons maintenant de la de
la caraïbe d'abord de la guadeloupe 300
euros pour aller en guadeloupe à ce que
c'est pas chez ce que
vous trouvez ça sert vous aviez
l'habitude de à écouter 3 est au poil en
guadeloupe
là il faudrait voir ce qui ferait on est
connaît à peine 300 euros parce que
n'oubliez pas qu'il y ait accès aux
produits simples et c'est ça qui grèvent
le bleu le prix aujourd'hui je pense que
c'est ça l'essence le plus l'importance
qu'ont médiatique très important je
prends l'exemple bien simple fait je
crois qu'on fait la différence on peut
ni ce paris nice retrouve à la taxe est
opportune à elle est moindre par rapport
aux taxes et aux pointures
fort-de-france pointe-à-pitre chasse est
associé un problème important
on a parlé de la guadeloupe on va
revenir aux puces de la caraïbe mais
aussi si on a encore le temps puisqu'il
reste pas beaucoup de temps on va parler
aussi de la de la guyane
les choses sont en train de bouger en
train de bouger là la guyane est que
j'ai envie de le dire le dernier bastion
de la france au départ des antilles
françaises
ça veut dire qu'ils ont le monopole mais
les flammes ont peut être changé dans le
temps n'oublions pas que l'essentiel de
la clientèle est en france
65% 70 des haïtiens les haïtiens sont le
montrent une compagnie aérienne qui
s'appelle selon us airways cette
compagnie aérienne est dédié à la
diaspora haïtienne ça veut dire que
depuis pratiquement moins de huit mois
ils font des vols vers de dix nations
unies jackson tango du chili ont
commencé des voitures
hollande aux états unis etc etc et cette
compagnie pour venir aussi faire du du
port au prince cayenne
la france aussi propose au pot du propre
camp ennemi sans monopole nom pourrait
pas voir sunrise arrivée en martinique
faire du peu du du cayenne du force du
fort de france cayenne pour se faire
menacer l'asile dans un autre temps
voilà pour le caribou
vous avez parlé de le fond de france
potable il faut manquer au kiel pompage
de deux compagnies aériennes air
anti-acariens caraïbes voit la cdu
compagnie là aussi ont leurs atouts
respectifs
air caraïbes propose des vols
domestiques faut le faux tapis de ces
menteurs cette garantie aussi proposer
le volant mais air antilles sont
avantageux pour faire aussi proposer des
vols dans la caraïbe comme porto rico
santo domingo
sainte-lucie barba les chrétiens à la
crise adducteurs est tellement de choses
encore à dire jean tout cas je vous
remercie je rappelle que vous êtes un
spécialiste de tout ce qui touche à
l'aviation et à l'aérien bonne journée
et merci encore bonne journée aller
coûte de nos programmes
[Musique]